a new poll says americans think the
country is moving in the wrong direction
optimism about where we are headed as a
nation over the next year
dropping nearly 20 points since may with
55
saying they felt pessimistic about the
future but can you blame them
try walking down the street in any major
liberal city nypd releasing new video of
a brutal mugging
showing the effects of an unpoliced city
a low life repeatedly punching
and kicking a 68 year old man it's as
old as killmead
knocking him unconscious and then
rifling through his pockets
i wonder if the press will be as
attentive to these videos
as they were for those in which police
were involved but progressive democrats
who pushed for less police aren't
worried
they're too busy hiring their own
private security to keep them safe
campaign filings reveal squad member
corey bush spent 70 grand
on private security while calling to
defund police
trey gowdy ripping into the hypocrisy
i don't know about your city or state
but seventy thousand dollars would get
you your own personal police officer
in south carolina 24 hours a day
seven days a week corey bush tells us
she is progressive the better word
might be hypocritical she wants to
defund
your police while she has a robust
personal security detail
in washington and st louis
that's trey gowdy dana you're aware of
him yes great show on the weekend
congrats
welcome back good to see you and you're
so brave thank you you're really good i
feel a lot better now yes exactly
help me keep strong that's good um so
anyway we're seeing these videos now
the police are i believe realizing how
important it is
to show what's going on on the street
because for so long
all you saw were the the things in which
they were involved in and now we're
seeing what happens when the police
aren't around i'd like to coin a phrase
this is what you can do when you fight
fire with fire
um but i think that the videos are the
things that
people are reacting to yeah and we saw
that and as you mentioned
obviously there when there have been
videotapes
of police brutality we've seen that and
there is a big reaction to it
i think that some of these videos i
don't know why all of a sudden like the
nypd is doing this but i
would imagine it's because they realize
that we need to be explicit and be
persuasive
one of the ways that you're persuasive
is to show yeah and they have the video
and it's there for everyone to see and
something like that can spur action
right can i comment on
the poll yes because it takes a long
time
to build up enough trust to get to a 64
percent approval rating
and and just like a moment to lose it
but they're blowing past all the stop
signs like you could
i guess they don't watch fox you could
do like a fox news alert here fyi
immigration
crime um the pandemic response the um
inflation education there's all these
things but they're so focused on trying
to pass
five trillion dollars in long-term
spending and
all these things that they want to do
which on their merits look like have a
fight about it
but if that doesn't pass or like even if
it does pass all these other things are
happening
and we're living in the middle of this
political realignment right that they
might really have something that they're
going to have to deal with
the fact that um that they're at the
white house thinking oh gosh maybe we
should do something like a speech is not
going to fix this
right the only thing that can fix this
is a policy pivot
and i don't think we're going to get one
yeah they can't admit there's that they
can't admit that they were wrong for so
long
brian you're used to that uh the experts
experts say the rise in pessimism
pessimism is directly related to you
hosting the seven pm prime times riley
i wrote this study i didn't say anything
about that and notice i'm not doing it
this week so i guess
uh a couple of things so i have to ask
permission every time i want to follow
up like dana or is this just a good
habit oh you could do whatever
you like uh i thought it's pretty uh one
thing is pretty clear
if uh the reason why people are
pessimistic is the fundamental issues
that have gone wrong not
little things it's not like a cultural
issue that we're on the other side of it
where you can sit there and have a good
debate
at a barbecue can i continue yes thank
you i was going to talk about if you
talk about voting that's fundamental
part of our democracy we're debating
that
and i think this totally inaccurate way
and they're being portrayed
when you talk about crime that's the
fundamental way in which we live when
you talk about inflation that's things
we buy
from the smallest to the biggest
everything that seems to be challenged
on a regular basis so it's going
i do not no longer feel confident and i
can actually see
the 20-point drop over the last three
months just from talking to people and
when it comes to crime this really has
changed
remember six months ago it was all about
the cops of the problem
and the cops just took a step back and
said take my badge and
i'm going to retire or i quit and now
every single one of these major cities
is depleted
it's like breaking up with a girl and
say see how life is at like without me
and then watching her life spiral down
that's never happened to you
and also you're supposed to ask
permission before you use an analogy
yes do you assume that when they break
up with you their life gets worse
yes that's right i'm just saying every
guy thinks that way
right and it's not
but that's what i'm saying and then in
front of you watch that person miss you
in front of you over the last year and
say do you want back in
that's what the cops are doing they're
out there and go what is life like
without me
that's all i got like in baltimore where
they're asking for 100 federal agents
now to come in and help
yeah i don't i don't even think that the
the opposite of optimism is pessimism
it's hopelessness
you know and hopelessness richard
arrives when you when you feel like
you're
you have no impact or your influence is
futile you're talking
about how much crime there is but no
one's doing anything
that's more hopelessness than pessimism
and i think that might be driving this
what do you think
well look when you watch videos like the
video we just saw there or you see a
video of a police officer beating
somebody up it doesn't matter it's
disgusting
to watch either of these cases right and
neither these things should be happening
in our streets
and i think that is where that's i think
where people are i think where people
are and i think a gallup poll points to
this that was done last year
especially in in black communities
they're saying look we want we like the
presence of police
oftentimes we feel like we're not
treated with respect and dignity and
encounters with police officers so it's
how do we create a balance here
how do we ensure that when police are in
our communities we're treated with
respect but how do we also deal with the
crime that's happening in our community
whether it's
the solving the case of little naya in
washington dc where i live or
it's ensuring that here in new york city
65 year old men don't get beat up by
crazy people right which is what's
happening and so we've got to figure out
how we rebalance this which is where we
are right now the system is unbalanced
and to some extent to dana's point um
you know yes i think the white house has
to do a little bit more and the
president has to have a little bit of a
stronger footing he
he has put out a plan only about guns he
seems to only no but
i think that's but that because that's
part of the problem right now and more
police right he said you could
move at relief money to hire more police
right dig into your savings
but that's part of it you have to hire
more police remembering that the number
one killer of police last year was
coronavirus
right that's that's according to officer
down the number one killer police
officers last year was covered 19.
so in order to get more boots on the
ground we have to hire more police
that's what mural bowser is doing in the
city of d.c she's taking the money from
the co the american rescue plan and
she's using it to put more police on the
ground
you know i want to get to dagan
richard brought up the black communities
i find it interesting that i don't
i think you're right it's the black
communities that are concerned about
crime
but all you see are the white leftists
the anti-foss and the activists
that are out there talking about
defunding more than anybody and they
don't have to live with the consequences
right i think i use the term soft
bigotry yes the soft bigotry that they
that people on the left ignored this for
the last year and a half when it was
hurting
communities throughout major cities uh
particularly
uh black and latino communities but only
when it arrives at their doorstep
like the shooting down in d.c do they
start giving a flying dam about it
right oh oh okay
you might i left of that restaurant dana
jim acosta goes there he's a lousy
tipper
i left my doorman building and i heard
shots when i was out dining with my
fancy friends and now i
lemon and i had a great meal there you
admit to that
um what amplifies the pessimism or
hopelessness that you were talking about
or exacerbates it is the total
disconnect between what people
are seeing and hearing in their everyday
lives
otherwise known as reality and the
garbage
that the left and liberals in power have
been
regurgitating in in people's faces and
what i mean is
our city is dangerous let me let me
explain
you just don't understand or gather news
from saying well crime is i don't know
what you're talking about crime's down
in the last 30 years
or joe biden saying defund the police we
never said defund the police they're
lying about it or
inflation oh it's running at the fastest
pace in
13 years to 30 years if you look at core
prices
that's just transitory that's just a
right wing
talking point the left they are
compulsively dishonest and also
irretrievably stupid that they can't see
what is in the
in the face of every american and just
one thing that's happening
i found this really interesting gallup
did a poll on confidence in
institutions that came out a couple of
weeks ago confidence for all
institutions is down this year except
for one the police
down the most for public schools because
the teachers unions essentially trampled
on children across the country for their
own power and the medical system
in part because of the poor messaging
from
washington yeah well i think but i think
to just think about it as just the
police is not the way to look at it when
you think about a community where little
nyaya died right in washington see this
also community doesn't have access to
broadband internet right this is a
community
that doesn't have resources they don't
have jobs so if you look at the if you
look at a map of december
but no but i'm talking about a broader
problem in the existing discussions
on the problem no but if you don't broad
but if you're just sitting here if
you're sitting here and just having a
conversation about oh
how do we solve the crime one way to
solve the crime is by providing
opportunity if you can't get online and
look for a job in this community because
you don't have broadband internet
and also then you have a problem i'm for
opportunity and i'm for people bad guys
having to stay in jail exactly no the
chief of police in
washington dc just gave press conference
this weekend yeah and he's furious about
it
absolutely because the courts aren't
open he even used i think we may
we have to make a right-wing talking
point pro-crime
because that's the only way the
democrats are going to be
anti-crime right because this is all
politically motivated yep
coming up everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now